zoos are slaughtering their own
perfectly healthy animals to save money
just let me explain so you're a zoo
owner you make millions of dollars
putting animals on display for the
public families come from far and wide
so their kids can see monkeys tigers
bears with their own eyes and they're
willing to pay big bucks for the
privilege I mean can you really put a
price tag on the look of Joy on your
kid's face it's a magical profitable
experience but in 2020 Kobe changed
everything suddenly people weren't going
to zoos and spending money anymore they
weren't going anywhere but Zeus couldn't
just shut their doors like most
businesses they own thousands of living
animals that needed food and care and
with no money coming in if they didn't
figure out a way to minimize expenses
the zoos would be in big trouble so
there was only one solution Slaughter
the least profitable animals and feed
them to the most valuable ones this
solved two problems at once you will get
free food and you would have less
animals to take care of it was brilliant
think about it some animals bring in
more customers than others tigers and
lions are big ticket animals while
zebras and monkeys they have a lot less
demand so why not feed the zebras and
monkeys to the lions and tigers and
that's exactly what you did a zoo in
Northern Germany said they would slowly
kill off all their animals until the
price polar bear Vitas was the only one
left standing at 12 foot tall Vitas was
the biggest polar bear in the whole
country and visitors would come to the
zoo just to see him which meant that he
was too valuable to allow to starve it
was worth murdering every other animal
in the zoo if it meant keeping him alive
the Zeus swore that they were only
taking such Extreme Measures because of
the pandemic they said nobody was
helping them and they were left with no
other choice it was an emergency but the
truth is killing off Surplus animals as
zoos is nothing new over 5 000 healthy
animals are euthanized in European zoos
alone every single year why because
money of course take Mario's a draft for
example two-year-old Marius was shot to
death because the Copenhagen Zoo
determined that his genes were too
common for breeding no breeding meant no
money Marius wasn't going to be
profitable and that meant there was no
reason to keep him alive so the zoo gave
him one final meal of rye bread his
favorite before shooting him in the hood
this giraffe walked out here at quarter
past nine it was let out into its yard
over there then there was a zookeeper
with some rye bread it really likes rye
bread and he said here you go Marius
here's some rye bread I stood behind
with a rifle and when he put his head
forward and ate the rye bread then I
shot him through the brain it sounds
violent but it means that Marius had no
idea of what was coming he got his bread
then he died but they weren't done yet
they had a perfectly good piece of meat
on their heads now so once the dirty
work was done they dissected marius's
body and fed his remains to the zoo's
Lions right in front of a huge crowd
What followed the shooting was a public
carving of the caucus a British Zoo had
offered to give Marius a home and an
online petition resulted in more than 25
000 signatures instead he would provide
the meals for other animals in the zoo
with officials confirming the carcass
would be fed to its lines polar bears
and tigers
how the zoo killed this giraffe shot it
instead of lethal injection tell me why
that's because if we shoot it we can
feed it to the carnivores afterwards if
we do it with an ejection we cannot feed
it to anybody then we just have to
dispose of the meat or just throw it
away just put the cream the zoo also has
Predator animals of course if we don't
use these animals to feed them we'd have
to order sides of beef from somewhere
people around the world were horrified
despite the protests that came from
around the world shot dead Mario's
people Love Giraffes murderers they
wanted the zoo shut down immediately and
all the animals saved but what all these
outraged people didn't know is that
being killed by the zookeepers is
probably the best thing that could have
happened to these animals because the
things that happened in these zoos when
they're alive are even more terrifying
than their gruesome death what do you
think
closed
stay dangerous subscribe for more and
this is the deranged business of zoo use
[Music]
prices
so I hope you're not in the zoo business
but if you are in a business where you
have to ship orders then spending the
next 60 seconds to learn about our
sponsorship station is gonna save you a
ton of money shipstation makes shipping
stuff easier than ever by letting you
automate most of your manual work while
also hooking you up with the best
shipping rates out there with up to 84
off from Top carers like UPS USPS and
DHL Express there's a reason why huge
Brands like Joe Rogan's on it uses them
with shipstation you don't need to
manually track pending orders or go to a
dozen shipping websites to find and
print affordable labels you can import
orders automatically from whatever
platform you're selling on compare
shipping rates right on shipstation and
then print custom branded discounted
shipping labels all in one place and the
best part is that shipstation takes less
than five minutes to set up you start by
creating an account then you connect to
whatever selling platform you use
Shopify Amazon Etsy eBay in fact most
marketplaces and stores are supported
and finally you just connect your
shipping carrier accounts and that is it
you are ready to start getting all the
benefits of shipstation including
instant tracking updates for your
customers and a carrier rate comparison
tool so start saving money on shipping
right now by going to shipstation.com to
get a free 60-day trial that's
shipstation.com for a free 60-day trial
with the link below thanks to
shipstation for sponsoring this video
foreign
ever since the beginning of civilization
rich people have always been looking for
ways to show off how powerful they are
sure you could have a big castle and you
could get endless luxury items but those
things are relatively easy to get once
you have them how do you differentiate
yourself from the other king over there
by owning the most exotic dangerous
animals on the planets think about it if
you're strong enough to capture and keep
alive a lion a tiger or a bearer then
you must be a pretty powerful person
killing a lion or a bear was a big deal
but brings me back a live one showed
even more power virtually all the
history of Zeus is about human control
of nature it was the ultimate status
symbol and it was a way of showing off
Queen Charlotte her gift to everybody
that she liked was to give them a
kangaroo
these private animal collections known
as menageries started over 4 000 years
ago ancient civilizations would go on
Expeditions just to bring back all the
most interesting and vicious animals
they could find to keep in captivity
then the Age of Enlightenment rolled
around all of a sudden people wanted to
know everything about the world around
them including animals people realized
that Zeus didn't have to just be a
symbol of wealth but they could also be
perfect for learning about nature and
the animal kingdom zoos were the
opportunity to see these beasts with our
own eyes and it all started in France
the animals from the elite menageries
were confiscated and relocated into the
very first modern zoo in Paris and they
opened their doors to the public so
everyone could enjoy the magic of seeing
Nature's creatures locked away and this
zoo is still in operation to this day
public zoos changed everything to be
able to suddenly see a giraffe for the
first time probably it was absolutely
Bonkers and people loved it everyone was
rushing in to see these ferocious
animals with their own two eyes and just
like that Zeus went from a luxury item
for the rich to a big public business
early zoos were brutal people didn't
really view animals as living breathing
beings with needs they were just an
object to show off for the public nobody
really stopped to think how captivity
might affect these wild animals
especially once money got involved it
wasn't really an appreciation of animals
needing certain things to have a good
life so you would see them in Barren
boxes effectively just as you would see
a specimen a natural history museum back
then people didn't believe animals felt
things the same way as humans so they
had no problem throwing them in an empty
cage all alone for years animals were
thought of as basically ultimate towards
just responding in a reflexive manner
with no feelings of pain or any kind of
emotional depth But as time went on
though this depressing cold model of
Zeus became less favorable nobody wanted
to see gorillas and lions and monkeys
miserable in empty cells all day zoos
needed to Rebrand their image enter
conservation the perfect rebranding to
get people back in the door spending all
their money at Zeus all they had to do
was tell everyone that Zeus were
actually the ones protecting animals
they started designing enclosures that
mirrored the animal's natural habitats
to make them seem more comfortable in
confinements they told the world how
they were the ones saving endangered
species by keeping them safe and helping
them breed that zoos were important
because they taught kids about wildlife
and made them care more about the
environments The Zoo by becoming a
public attraction if it's done properly
it seems to me like a pretty good idea
the animals have a good life people
enjoy it they learn something hopefully
they get involved in conservation
Jews has successfully flipped the
narrative from being a form of Ruthless
entertainment to a societal good that we
all needed it wasn't about profit it was
about educating the masses and
safeguarding these animals who could
argue with that and made visitors want
to spend their money there even more
because they thought every single penny
was going towards supporting these
helpless animals but it wasn't outright
lie see some Zeus do help with
conservation work and have even saved
some species from going extinct
[Music]
Sioux populations of animals are
Insurance populations
certain species due to what's going on
on the planet at the moment the only way
that we can stop them from going extinct
will be to bring them into captivity but
most views don't even have to try that
hard they seem like they're saving the
planets all they have to do is put a
tiny percentage of their funds into
conservation programs and boom they're
making millions while looking like the
good guys the official statistics show
that four percent of Revenue goes back
into conservation I mean that's minimal
it's very small and what do you find in
these big cats and elephants and zebra
and things that don't get released back
into the wild but the reality is even
more depressing
[Music]
except for the animals that are like
really endangered and they protect them
and help breed them and then sometimes
they're responsible for some
reintroduction efforts there is no way
to sugarcoat it zoos are animal presence
and when you take a look at how zoo
animals behave after being locked up for
years it's obvious that they want outs
those are all signs that they're missing
out on some important aspect of how they
live in the wild the complexity of
providing a good life for some of these
animals that's actually really really
difficult after a while of being held
captive zoo animals are pacing around
aimlessly rocking back and forth and
pulling out their hair sometimes they
even start eating their own feces and
self-harming themselves by biting
themselves and what's sad is that almost
every single zoo animal starts
developing these behaviors after being
held captive for a long time I'm not
against all Zeus but I have to say that
there's nothing more sad than seeing
elephants cats bears in cats man the
cats when they're pacing back and forth
I mean just get them out of there
who sir whose purpose are you serving is
that good for you I mean seeing an
animal that's got zucosis I mean it's uh
it's it's it's a mental case which is
why whenever they get the chance zoo
animals try their best to escape
elephants try to run away when given the
slightest opportunity gorillas have been
known to pick the locks or bend the bars
on their cages to try to free themselves
[Music]
[Applause]
and sometimes these animals resort to
Desperate Measures
thank you
it's 2007 at the San Francisco Zoo three
teenage boys are enjoying a day out
seeing the animals when they stumbled
upon the cage of Tatiana the tiger the
boys started messing with a 350 pound
tiger throwing sticks and pine cones at
her to try to rile her up but Tatiana
was not in the mood that day and she had
had enough of the taunting so the
massive deadly tiger ran and leaped the
12-foot wall of her enclosure and went
right after the boys she immediately
pounced on one of them killing him
almost instantly the other boys ran as
fast as they could but they were no
match for the full-grown tiger she
hunted them down like prey ignoring
every other person in her path she
managed to mop both of the boys before
being shot to death by police on the
scene it was horrifying but it wasn't a
one-off incident tragic attacks happen
all the time in zoos and Aquariums
killer whale grabs his feet and pulls
him underwater for close to a minute
then it brings him to the surface where
the trainer Pets the whale tries to calm
it only to be yanked down again
experienced trainer killed by an
elephant he helped raise showing new
video and audio just released from
deputies who responded to that tiger
attack at a Florida Zoo get out
[Music]
hey
a terrifying incident at a zoo in
Phoenix a woman attacked and seriously
hurt by a Jaguar while trying to take a
selfie next to the animal's cage even if
they're locked away in cages and kept in
captivity from the second they're born
these are still wild animals trapped
wild animals and they fight back with
deadly force whenever they get the
opportunity but fear not because we have
the solution you just gotta prescribe
the animals Prozac we don't know what
the [__] is going on in their head so we
have no idea and most people just watch
and think this is just maybe normal or
something ah yes remove them from nature
lock them in an artificial environments
make them work a job they hate
surrounded by people they hate and when
they inevitably develop mental problems
instead of freeing them and letting them
back into nature diagnose them and
prescribe them a bunch of drugs wow it's
like zoos are a parody of the 21st
Century
and by the way guys we have a Spanish
version of this channel if you didn't
know about it so if you have people in
your life that mainly speak Spanish and
you think these videos are important for
them to watch click the card on the
screen for the new Spanish version of
our video on the vatican's unimaginable
wealth to share with them this really
helps give the algorithm a nice little
boost so click the card on the screen to
watch and share with them now
foreign
[Music]